piles of metal including artillery
shells on board a Chinese registered
vessel these are believed to be material
taken from the undersea wrecks of two
British battleships from World War II
Malaysian coast guards initially
detained the ship for anchoring
illegally
but the police and the Heritage
Department are now investigating whether
it was involved in looting the warships
one of them is the HMS repulse built
during the first world war it was
deployed to protect British colonies
from the Japanese invasion during the
second world war but just days after the
bombing of the Pearl Harbor in December
1941 it was sung along with the
battleship Prince of Wales by the
Japanese Navy
the two ships now lie deep in waters off
the east coast of the Malaysian
Peninsula the wrecks are considered War
Graves divers say the HMS repulse is
more accessible as it lies in shallower
waters but it has deteriorated in the
last few years damage to the hull of the
wreck where it looks like somebody has
started pulling away sheets of metal and
with that what was inside the wreck has
started to come outside so the Munitions
cases and the 15-inch showcasing has is
now visible and some of it has fallen
outside material from old warships
produced before the atomic explosions in
the Japanese cities of Hiroshima and
Nagasaki in 1945 is highly prized
pre-war steel as it's known is used to
manufacture sensitive equipment
including radiation detectors this is
not the first time the Chinese vessel
trundhong 68 has been in Malaysian
Waters it was detained in 2017 for
anchoring illegally and released after a
fine was paid but before that the vessel
was found Scavenging from another
shipwreck according to the Indonesian
Navy and it moved to international
waters before it could be detained a
maritime lawyer says existing laws to
protect such sites are sufficient but
enforcement agencies should find better
ways to deter illegal salvages as far as
surveillance is concerned you can
actually partner with diving
organizations you can also employ
Marine assets to be vigilant night and
day to monitor the sea and of course you
can also use drones aerial drones
underwater drones to also see what's
going on as well
besides the two battleships hundreds of
other wrecks also sit in Southeast Asian
Waters
and our prime target for illegal
salvages
Florence Louis Al Jazeera Kuala Lumpur